in 1963 the first mobster received
protection from the federal government
in exchange for testimony against mob
cohorts a move that marked the beginning
of what would become the federal witness
security program or WITSEC next Gerald
sure who is credited with founding the
organization and journalist Pete Earley
discussed their book by the same name
with details on the more than 6,400
protected witnesses responsible for over
10,000 convictions this program runs 35
minutes good evening everyone my name is
Greg Schuyler I am the community
relations director here for Pfizer Noble
in Georgetown thank you very much for
being here this evening and eBooks has
put out Whitsett inside the federal
witness protection program everything
you want to know about my few figures
and crime lords that squeal on their own
will find out exactly what kind of life
they lead we welcome the authors of this
book shelter Peter Lee we thank you very
much for being with us thank you very
much thanks very much sir
I'm Peter Lee I'm the co-author along
with Gerald and I'm gonna start tonight
a microphone here hook I must tell you
it's a little intimidating because I
look out in the audience I realize how
many of you folks have worked in the
program and know it know it quite well
so I guess we get a jam on a question
we'll just take a show of hands and
whoever handled handled that case can do
it I'm gonna start by doing a reading
from the book it's gonna be very short
and I actually typed it out and I did
that because I swear to you it is in the
book but I did it because I didn't want
to wear my glasses and I don't know if I
can read this small print this is from
the book this was a lady in Brooklyn and
this is what she told me and I'd like to
share with you this is how it happens
you're cooking dinner your son is
playing with carmine the kid next door
and your baby is taking a nap
your sisters stopped by and you're
gossiping about the woman who's
having sex with this Jewish guy who owns
a corner deli and there's a knock and
when you open the door to Marshalls show
you badges and your life suddenly ends I
mean I had tomato sauce simmering I knew
my husband Sal was thinking about
cooperating with the cops the last time
I'd seen him in jail he told me he was
going to go down for a long time 15 or
20 years he was worried but I had no
warning one of the u.s. marshals
introduces himself and says real polite
like that we got to go like right now
he says Sal is in protective custody
which means everybody in jail knows he's
a rat which means his boss Tony may be
sending guys over right now
to whack us this other marshal he keeps
looking outside as if somebody's coming
Anna she's my only sister and me send
carmine home and start grabbing
swimsuits t-shirts baby stuff and I wake
up Maria my two year old I come out of
the bedroom and Ana is arguing with the
marshals because they're saying she and
our grandfather have to come with us too
since Tony might go after them
now Ana lives with our grandfather there
are a few buildings down and the marshal
says there's another marshal down there
getting him right now and and I just
look at each other we're thinking oh
yeah the captain leaving that's not
going to happen we call him the captain
because he wears a blue sailor's cap he
has since war war one the marshals drive
us down to where Ana and the captain
live and I run upstairs still carrying
Marie and try to talk to him but the
captain says he's staying put so I
signed some stupid paper from the
marshals about how they tried but he
refused to go and Ana comes and gets in
the van with her suitcase and her puppy
now the puppy's part German Shepherd and
part Labrador Retriever and John loves
him but Maria is scared and starts
fussing again what a sight
we're all crowded in this van with these
two marshals there's another car behind
us with another two marshals and we're
all afraid Tony's crew is going to come
racing up and open fire meanwhile all
around us life is going on as normal
people are walking their dogs talking to
neighbors and us hurrying around I don't
think I really understood what leaving
meant until we pulled away there wasn't
time to think and then I looked through
the glass and there's the captain
standing on the porch stoop watching us
go for God's sakes how safe is that the
captain's angry but he has tears in his
eyes and suddenly I'm blubbering like a
baby and then Anna starts and the kids
begin and even the dog starts whimpering
and these marshals are trying to get us
quiet and the next thing you know we're
pulling out of Brooklyn where I've lived
my entire life 27 years never having
gone no further than New Jersey in the
shore and I'm thinking to myself what
the hell is going to happen now now as
terrible as that situation may sound
that's a vast improvement over what this
person would have faced only a few years
earlier before Gerald sure and several
people in this audience helped started
the federal witness protection program
back in the 1960s the mob really
controlled an awful lot of businesses
and industries and anyone who had enough
guts to step forward and testify against
them ended up and a lot of times dead we
begin the book with the scene where
there's a witness who has found an
informant who is found and her throats
been slit and her innards have actually
been pulled out a literal message sent
to people if you spill your guts about
the mob they'll literally spill your
guts so the program that mr. Sher
started gave people an option I got
interested in the book before I met
Gerald sure I was trying to find people
in the program because I'd heard a lot
of negative things about it and it's
easy to find people if you're only
looking for the complainers and I
realized quickly that I was only getting
a very small part of the story I ran
into Gerald sure and I discovered he was
doing his own book and I said hey
instead of us competing you've been
there since Joe Valachi all the way to
Sammy the bull you know more about this
program that I ever will
let's throw in together and let's do a
book together and luckily he agreed
Gerald sure well we agreed but only
after we met and decided we could fall
in love
the first problem I had was here I was
dealing with a guy who has a reporter's
background and you remember some of you
how report his treatise and so I had you
know wonder whether or not he's going to
be objective whether he'd be fair of
course what's in his mind is he's
dealing with someone who was in the
government and he knows they're never
fair they're never straightforward and
he has the same suspicions that I have
of each other and by talking we began to
realize that what we wanted to do was
put together a solid history of what we
think of as a very important program I
had the advantage of a very skillful
writer he had the advantage of someone
who could make it up as he goes along
we're going to use it and and he had
Pappas journal which is what I called my
first work there I was actually writing
this for my grandchildren at Miriam's
suggestion and so we got together and in
fact the marriage was formed the one way
we ensure the integrity of the book was
we had an agreement that if either one
of us wanted to write something that the
other didn't like about facts in the
case if we disagreed we each would write
that he could write his paragraph as he
saw the case I could write the next
paragraph and say this is why it was
different and we had that understanding
and that that ensured the integrity of
the book the nice thing about it is
neither of us ever had to resort back to
that we will let me interrupt here I'll
show you how quickly my fears went away
the very first line very first sentence
in this book is Gerald sure thought he
was going to vomit and I showed that to
Gerry he goes that's great that's
wonderful and I thought hey
this guy's gonna be easy to work with
after he left I went inside and threw up
yeah but with that and with constant
questioning I mean I had I had to be on
my toes because I have a very very
skillful analyst over here skillful
reporter and very skillful writer and
he's probing me and probing and making
me really reach reach and defend this
program and do what we were doing and he
did it more intelligently than anybody
else who would ever question me and and
together I think we have put together
what is the real history of the witness
program and with the help of some very
wonderful people who used to be in the
Marshal Service and Bureau of Prisons
and the federal investigative agencies
all of whom wanted to see a straight
honest history put forward the most
satisfying thing I've had so far out of
the book besides the completion of the
book itself into working was that
several people who have worked in the
program have written to us and told us
how wonderful they think the book is now
honest they think it is and people sort
of on both sides so that that is a
warning delightful experience for
someone who's trying to put forth an
honest history you've said so many nice
things about me I think one of the
reasons why and I'd never written a book
with anybody else one of the reasons I
wanted to do that was because Jeri
really had been there I mean he dealt
with Joe Valachi who was the very first
person to really come forward and talk
about the mob he dealt with Sammy the
bull and one of the unique things I
discovered which he really doesn't like
to talk about was he and his wife Miriam
had to go into the program at a certain
point because the Colombian cartel had
decided that a good way to find a
witness was to kidnap Jerry or Miriam
torture him and then find out this name
and I found that incredible and in fact
one of the problems we had was that I
felt like a dentist pulling teeth trying
to get him to talk about some of this
because at one point Jerry's is living
on a houseboat in the middle of night
wakes up and there's these five guys on
motorcycles who come down the middle all
night and they're all looking at his
houseboat so he gets out this automatic
weapon and
Miriam the phone she's sitting there
with a revolver and they're looking
through a night-vision scope at these
folks waiting for him to see if they're
going to come up and try to take him
hostage and you know I'd say things like
oh my gosh you know wow what do you feel
well I'd do what was necessary oh no no
you can say more than that how's this
sound
he had the focus terrifying fingers
Miriam holding a revolver I wasn't
worried those five but yes the probably
comes the reporters and you know any
other end but what we did we sat there
that night and it was it was frightening
we had night-vision cameras on put on by
the Marshal Service and and suddenly we
hear the roar of those motorcycles and
we look on our we had monitors all
through the boat Peake says houseboat it
was actually a trawler wasn't a
houseboat it was meant to actually move
it had a motor in it and and we was
sitting there and we're watching the
camera and I zoom in on these guys and I
can barely see in the dark and we did
was sitting there with a with a machine
gun and a shotgun and a revolver and a
telephone and we waited until they
passed around something that they all
puffed on and then they left and went
away she's your typical federal
bureaucrats out for a ride that's right
that was it but I think one thing that
you told me about that there I thought
was very interesting was that when I was
out interviewing people trying to find
people in the program they all told me
these stories where they'd be hidden and
they'd walk into a grocery store and by
God there was somebody from their
neighborhood and that happened to you
you ran into that and also I just how
odd
several times things that you think
would never happen like forgetting your
name those things do happen I remember
one time you told me Miriam looked out
the window and someone was crawling into
her car and she immediately assumed it
was somebody planting a bomb there it
turned out to be a gas station guy who
had been sent to pick up a car and the
guy had said I'll put my keys on the
back wheel but when you're in this
situation where you think your life's
threatened and you're thinking you know
could be anything you see things
differently right Miriam was on the
phone I called the police and the police
in turn had called me and I was on my
way home at the time and so I started
zooming up well beyond that 60 mile
limit going on home and went to by the
time I got got home there were two
police cars had stopped this truck
coming up from where the where the
Miriam's car was and and I came out and
we all had a nice chat and it turned out
the two guys were mechanics who were
just about to pass out I mean they were
absolutely devastated because when I
arrived they took officers they'd have
their guns drawn and they were you know
things were not going well for these two
guys who just wanted to pick up the car
unfortunately the car why they wanted to
pick up look exactly like Miriam's and
they got under the wrong car which they
probably never never did again but dia
but memory was a problem when you know
Miriam was teaching at the time when
when the kidnapping was going to occur
and when I first told her about it after
I learned that day that there was this
plan I asked her if she wanted to leave
and she said I can't leave I have my
first grade class to tend to then here
on one hand I'm telling she's going to
be tortured and she's worried about the
first grade class I then called the
Marshal Service and asked that they send
some protection for my wife they found
an absolutely delightful wonderful
deputy who posed as a student teacher
with the blessings of the principal of
the school principals school was the
only one that was told the truth and
they all agreed everybody understood
that Miriam was not presenting a danger
to the children she was in danger on her
way to and from school but not at school
and so she had this undercover marshal
who was grading papers for her and under
her coat of course was her weapon and
such and so if these first graders got
out of line with
they were going to be handled
appropriately but I want to tell one
story before we open it to questions
this is one I ran into and I was out in
California and I was talking to some
marshals and maybe a little racy but it
just shows the kind of problems that
Gerald sure had to deal with because you
had dysfunctional people who were being
brought into this program and trying to
get them into normal society and I think
it's a funny funny story had a mobster
who got into the program and it was very
tough on him to testify against his
buddies and his self-esteem went down
and of course the marshal is working
with him trying to get him pumped up so
he could testify and finally the guy
said to him I'm just so devastated he
said you know I can't even satisfy my
wife and so the guy sent him to a
psychiatrist and the psychiatrist came
back and said that's the true story said
I think a penal implant would help this
guy out I think it really booster his
ego and it'd really be a good thing to
do so they did it and he did a great job
testifying everything is fine about a
month later the marshal got a call he
says everything's great except I got a
problem okay said well what's that and
he says well they put this wire in that
makes this work he said they put it
right above my belly button he says
every time I lean forward to eat at the
table the button hits the table he says
this is very embarrassing and
uncomfortable and the marshal looked at
him and said well why don't you get a
taller table or a shorter chair now
that's really the witness program
practical solutions for practical
problems the now you made me nervous
here a little while but anybody have any
questions so long the way that you want
to ask yeah place we go on if you have a
question anybody well yeah yes questions
okay so yeah yes I spend part of your
book like what you're giving witness
protects
identity don't you why don't you have
the financial records I was very
concerned when we started the program
since we were dealing with people who
like to steal that if we gave them full
backgrounds with financial records we
would be helping them steal and so I
decided there were alternatives to
giving him background direct full
backgrounds they didn't need financial
records they didn't need employment
records because I had gone out and
contacted 150 or 200 employers in the
country who agreed to hire witnesses in
the very beginning that was the first at
the start of it and so they didn't have
to have those background records subsidy
it turned out to be that is what they
did do many of them who didn't have
backgrounds from us went out committed
fraud anyway and I was glad that we did
not give him the background well I think
it'd be helpful if you understand that
when Gerald sure took a mobster he had
to say okay how am I going to give this
guy a new identity well he needs a
social security number because he's
going to have to work he needs a new
driver's license but want to keep it a
minimum maybe we'll get new school
records for his kids but I don't want to
vouch for him financially and this made
it tough and there's 5% of the people in
the program who were not involved or
found guilty of any crimes now imagine
being 42 being sent from New York
because you'd seen a crime out to Rapid
City South Dakota and walking in at age
42 and not being able to have a credit
report get a telephone hooked up that
kind of thing but the worst part when I
talk to these people the number one
thing that drove him crazy was they felt
like they'd really lost their identity
and lost their self they hated that they
couldn't stay with their family deal
with her family and I found a lot of
them who after a few years just made
that contact or moved or whatever but
this one woman who's in the book witness
X told me she said it was you you lost
your name you lost who you were and I
never realized how much of our
individuality depends on this talking
about the past where I went to school
who my friends were all I guess he lost
all that and I think the main reason she
talked to me was she had lost both of
her children and accidents and she felt
like she'd been on this earth and nobody
knew it didn't matter sure her whole
self had been erased and I think she was
desperate to try to say I'm here I
mattered I'd lived and I think that's
something that they faced
those same psychological reasons many of
the witnesses begin to use the term week
where after we relocate and they talk
about we're going to prosecute we're
going to get a conviction we're going to
do this and we're going to do that and
what you're doing is substituting the
agents and the prosecutors and us for
their family back home and so and you
had to watch out for the we because if
they start saying we too much they might
deviate from the truth and you wanted
him to stay with the truth I recall one
fellow who absolutely bragged about how
he had his own office in the United
States Attorney's Office and he was
going there every day and had his own
office with a desk and he said I have my
own secretary which surprised me because
we were scrambling for secretaries than
the Department of Justice and his fellow
who like to kill got his own secretary
in the US Attorney's Office but the the
use of the we became very important to
them otherwise they had nothing nothing
to hold on to also they've come out of a
gang the gang is gone there was
something in the gang now they're in
their eyes nothing in this civilian non
criminal world and it's you know what do
I do now I'm not who I was I'm not
important and also another problem they
had they had to stay with their wives
and their children normal hours
something the first racketeers we
relocated we're not used to doing back
in New York you know typically they
would go out at 6:00 or 7:00 in the
evening and they come back at 5:00 in
the afternoon
now we've relocated them and they have
to get a job working from 9:00 to 5:00
and for a long time we couldn't get them
jobs that meant they were sitting in
motels with their wives and their
children from 9:00 in the morning till
9:00 the next morning till 9:00 the next
morning and they found that absolutely
intolerable I think another thing you
need to realize is that these folks
Gerry not only had to hide the witness
but anybody the mob could get to and so
there were situations like that one
where the mobster said I don't care
about you hiding my wife but don't hide
my mystery and he'll hide my wife don't
hide my mistress but don't hide my wife
right right I was going to be his answer
to it you know don't get it divorced
here I don't need to spend the money I
got this guy who will leave my wife back
in the home area and that will solve the
problem and we relocated his wife of
course anyway but
I think another thing that one of the
problems that I was very interested in
was with Vinny fat Teresa fat Vinny
Teresa who got into the program a guy
who weighed what over 300 pounds and I
found this typical of some of the big
shots like Jimmy the weasel and others
they loved the fame they loved the
attention they loved bringing down the
big mobster and they didn't want to
disappear and so one of the problems you
ran in with Vinny is he actually started
making stuff up and trying to stay as
much as he could in the limelight the
first problem I ran to with Vinny was
was after we we sent to a hospital lose
weight and on his way out of the
hospital after he successfully lost some
weight he stopped and he had two or
three dozen donuts and the way they went
so you don't try that sort of thing I
mean don't don't do that again but the
he started to make up stuff about famous
people that he thought would be useful
for prosecutors always trying to really
sort of stay on the public dole and get
more money and but after a while we got
sort of savvy to that kind of thing and
as we gained experience we were with
taken less and we began to try to
out-con the con which is what it
amounted to I guess and sometimes we
were successful sometimes not now in in
this whole story about the witness
program and in a WITSEC it's not just
about the witnesses that we talk about
although they certainly are an important
part and I and we have to remember that
during my day we relocated about 6500
witnesses about 14,000 members of the
family about 20 21,000 people who were
relocated and almost enough to make
another community and relocated
successfully we talked about the
criminal part but there are the innocent
folks and those are the spouses and the
children and now in 2002 the Marshal
Service is dealing with the third
generation of some of those people and
some of those generations don't even
know that their grandparents were
criminals so that that factor the
innocent people in this program I think
tends to get lost with some of the
newspaper publicity and then there are
the investigative agencies that we don't
want to lose sight of I mean
the fact that the FBI and DEA and IRS
all these agencies are feeding into this
program and making their cases off of it
yes you had a question what kind of
obstacles were in your way in the early
days within the department itself the
biggest obstacle I had in the department
was money was getting money was hidden
well then call the administrative
division in a department who the
administrative division had no role in
anything substantive in a department as
far as I was concerned except they
controlled the budget and they saw no
need to hide people now they knew
nothing about fighting crime they know
nothing about crime itself they knew
about saving dollars and that was that
was their role I had a fixed budget and
I had to fit everything into that budget
so when I asked for money for a witness
they thought that these requests were
absolutely bizarre and I would fill out
a form and I would ask for some money
and for two thousand or three thousand
dollars and they were used to putting
out $8 a day for a witness to testify so
they couldn't understand why would we
need $2,000 or $3,000 and what do you
mean you're going to put them up in a
hotel or hide them and you're going to
have deputy marshals around a massage
that was that was the first big problem
I had the second problem was convincing
the agencies that the agencies that
we're going to do this work in this
program pure prisons US Marshal Service
that this is a good program for them and
I think in the case of the u.s. marshals
these people are trained to go out and
investigate and arrest apprehend
criminals and I come along and say I'd
like you folks to be social workers I
want you to take him to doctors I want
you to take him to schools you know I
want you to give him marriage counseling
and so on something that they just were
not accustomed to do I think one of the
things that surprised me too one reason
I was happy to work on the booklet but
Jerry is because you were on as there
were a couple times you told me you know
I put the wrong guy in the program I
should have put the guy he was
testifying in the program and he should
have testified against him and I think
one of the other things that was really
tough for you I remember one of your
most emotional sessions was we were
talking about the programs failures you
sound like my psychiatrist here the
emotional session
it was you're talking about Marian
Pruitt going on seven state crime spree
and killed people and you had to deal
with the parents calling up and saying
why do put this sob in the program and
turn him loose on the streets and it's
funny since we've been doing this book
tour we begin the same kind of questions
not about mafia but about terrorists
since the Marshal Service and WITSEC is
now hiding terrorist people saying we'll
put him next to my neighbor but don't
put him next to me you know right
well no but nobody wants a racket here
or criminal or terrorist or whatever
next to them at the but he days when I
started is so far back you know that the
when JK Hoover was head of the FBI there
were people who believed that we had put
a communist on one side of them in a
racketeer on the other side of him and
they would didn't going to be a killer
but us reporters and it was yes they
were a reporter that's right yeah so any
other questions yeah
yes just out of curiosity what what you
see is the biggest flaws biggest
failures in program
well the biggest fairies in the program
started on my watch
when I was there and I was responsible
for some of the biggest failures in the
program I've left so there is no more
fizz in the program like what how is I
think I think the biggest failure we
have in the program the most difficult
thing to this day is working with the
very innocent person who has absolutely
nothing to do with crime we can't pick
them up move them to another part of the
country and make them whole and make
them feel really good about themselves
with the criminal whom you do that to
the criminal has seen some benefit out
of this
but to the honest person that 5% or less
it's really tough on them and I think
that we still have a difficult time with
that yes I there any criminal who has
really flourished under it literally
they've taken that new the new
environment and they have gone on to be
very independent they vary they've just
come at different personal looks good
many criminals have flourished under it
we had we've had some rise so high at
the corporate level that I was concerned
that they would be disclosed and they
gotten up to corporate boards and such
most of them have done extremely well
and we have a 10% about 10% I think of
the people who have entered the program
have committed crime again compare that
to a normal state recidivism rate of 40
percent or 50 percent then the program's
done extremely well and that makes sense
because a guy gets out of prison give
150 bucks or whatever and say good luck
goodbye and in this program you're going
out and you're spending six months
getting them into the community helping
them adjust getting them jobs you know I
know so they know if they show up they
may be killed so that's a pretty good
incentive I one of the things that Jerry
told me was funny was they had a witness
who ran for mayor in a Texas and what'd
he say he said he was he was telling the
voters that he was a crook to begin with
instead of a after he elected and then
there was a case what you were worried
because a guy was in the punt his son
was in the putt has punt and kick yeah
and it looked like he was gonna win and
you were thinking what how in the world
are we gonna keep this guy hidden if
he's
down there with his son on national TV
Freddie be on national television right
then that would be a problem and he
didn't win so was not a problem
we fixed it so I said we did not I mean
I think that this is being uh this is on
c-span I suppose we should not we did
not fix it
it's just one let's just deal laughing
sweet huh okay it really didn't happen
yes somebody else had a question up here
yes how has organized crime changed
since the late 60s oh we know the
program was originally designed to
hide the identity of witnesses against
the Mafia
is that is that still true today the
Mafia has been decimated by the witness
protection program it absolutely has
been demolished they're still remnants
around and still functioning but they're
certainly do not have the capacity that
they had in the 1960s I think virtually
the heads of every major syndicate has
been put in jail or is about to go to
jail and the so so as far as the cousin
Oscar goes the program has been highly
successful it moved on from there to
motorcycle gangs and hate groups here in
Brotherhood and and on to terrorism and
program seems to be very adaptable to
the different kinds of people that it's
running up against and something in the
very beginning I really didn't think
about I thought about Casa Nostra and
then suddenly I find myself dealing with
motorcycle gangs and hate groups and I
found that the Marshal Service was very
very adaptable to that newer prisons I
mean something we've not mentioned us so
far Bureau prisons had to establish
witness security units to protect
prisoner witnesses and more than half of
the people who enter have entered the
program for the last several years we've
gone to prison for us and and then
another decision is made after it's time
for them to come out of prison whether
they should be relocated again but
Bureau of Prisons started out by
starting a unit in New York City on the
third floor of a high-rise jail in
effect and we put all of the prisoner
witnesses in there and then we needed a
second unit went to another high-rise
prison another high-rise prison and
through the good graces of the Bureau
prisons and their directors they finally
built regular prison units so that
prison where prisoner witnesses are
hidden in units which are inside of
prison so they go to prison and that's
important because the prosecutors and
agents begin to realize that we can keep
their witnesses alive and they don't
have to plea-bargain all the cases all
the way down I was impressed with the
marshals that I ended up interviewing
because as you said when this program
first started a lot of these guys were
trained to go out and hunt down bad guys
not help them and these guys were
protecting mobsters and they and they
were doing things mobsters are trying to
drop bombs down courthouse chimneys and
assassinate these people and I think a
lot of people
the wrong impression that it's the FBI
hiding them or some other agencies and
it's US Marshal Service US Marshals yeah
often you see on television so I've got
something about the witness program they
say the FBI did it or some agency I
never heard of a member interviewing
Jean [ __ ] and he told me the hardest
person for him as a u.s. marshal to hide
was an outlaw motorcycle gang member
because one he didn't want to be part of
normal society and two he had tattoos
all over him so you know you can hide
him in in Idaho but the first thing he
does is look for a biker bar how do you
protect somebody like that that was
until he wanted to hide me and I didn't
want to hide and gave him fits and he
said bring back the biker guy again I
didn't follow any rules but somebody had
a question over here today questions it
you think that the that since you have
gotten rid of the vast majority of the
high-ranking mafia that's the new groups
that are coming and have run the program
it's an interesting question I have the
new groups through in the program I
recall going to a witness security unit
a prison unit and walking through
walking through the unit and the
old-time Mafia Cosa Nostra guy pulls me
aside he says Jerry I got to talk to you
we got a problem and I what's the
problem he says you're not putting in
the same classic criminal used to you
know and in all I said what do you mean
he says you're bringing in these guys
here you got tattoos on you got guys in
here that want to kill ya guys it'll
kill anybody says we don't do that kind
of stuff we don't do that at all and so
that the type of person that's coming in
came was coming into the program after
the first ten or fifteen years I think
was very different was what dangerous in
certain ways I found that I could I
personally felt I could trust a cut what
a cousin austere person told me if they
said they would not do something they
didn't if they said they will do
something they did it was what they
didn't say I worried about with the
others that came in after them and the
motorcycle gangs and the hate groups and
they've just lied about everything and I
just had a great deal of difficulty with
them yes
anybody else yes
if it let me move away from Enron since
I know nothing about that case being a
private citizen now and I'm delighted if
if there were a case that involved fraud
and a criminal fraud and the person
where a person was endangered because
they became a whistleblower this program
would be broad enough to cover them and
protect them if they were in danger but
it would be a program you would not want
to go into unless it was the last resort
you know I think all of us kind of had
this fantasy at least I know when I
started researching this book I did
about wow you could erase your past you
could disappear you could get a new
identity you could start over and when I
talk these people I found out it was the
hardest thing any of them have ever done
and not I think the Congressional
studies showed 86% of the people were
happy that eventually but there was
still you know it's just so many
problems none of them said that they
would if they note all the problems they
would have really thought about it even
they didn't have a choice they had to do
it any other questions yes I'm glad you
asked that question have people been
murdered in the program I repeat Divac
sure everybody hears it no person who's
followed the rules has been murdered in
this program and I don't mean that as a
catchy title phrase you had some people
who just decided you know I'm a wise guy
I can handle myself and I'll just tell
everybody who I am we had one guy who
was hidden out west on California and he
got so excited when he saw that he was
on a network newscast
he ran next door to his neighbor and he
said hey turn it on that's me
we had one guy go back home to New
England when he was told not to go home
and he turned the doorknob and a house
blew up we've had those kind of deaths
we've had a few witnesses commit suicide
and that concerned me for some time and
I had a study done to see if there was
something we could do to prevent that or
if there was an excessive number of
suicides and the study revealed that the
number of suicides that occurred was not
disproportionate to the rest of the
population and that in effect I go back
to the old tort law that I learned in
law school you take the actor as you
find him right we take these people
in with whatever baggage they may have
and take them into the program relocate
them with their baggage and then we try
to deal with that baggage as best we can
yes why the witnesses go on TV and are
not killed I can't explain why they go
on TV easy I can explain why they're not
killed but uh I think I think that with
with the Casa Nostra type of witness
that went on television which I'm more
familiar with those that go on
television I think that the there wasn't
that desire to sort of reach out and
chase after them as much if they came
back to their home city I think they
would have been done in but I don't
think there was that ability that you'll
find with terrorist organizations for
the people to go out and do the
searching that they had most of them
were also on TV after they'd already
testified yeah it was it was after they
testify you but you would think they
would want to somebody would want to
Grail Ange her he does set an example to
the others not not to testify of course
they haven't been a whole lot that have
gone on TV and you've got one out there
now who's got his own internet site they
know he's he's everywhere he's very
public about it and I think time has
always been a factor when it came to the
cycle of risk and I always felt that
there was a timeline we could draw when
the witness was most at danger and when
he was least at danger and I think years
after the case is over he's least at
danger and we've had we've had witnesses
wind up meeting the people they
testified against on the street when
they've gone back to the same city and
they've not been hurt Jerald sure is the
founder of the federal witness
protection program reporter Pete Earley
has worked for a number of newspapers
including the Tulsa Tribune and the
Washington Post
WITSEC inside the federal witness
protection program is published by
banham del an imprint of Random House
visit Random House com
for more information